Hi. Welcome, everyone.
My name is Alda Migoni.
And I'm President of the
Hispanic Cultural Society here
at the Library of Congress.
I work as a librarian of
the South American section
of the African, Latin, American,
and Western European division.
On behalf of the Hispanic
Cultural Society of the Library
of Congress, I would
like to welcome you all
to this featured event in honor
of National Hispanic
Heritage Month.
National Hispanic Heritage
Month is celebrated each year
from September 15
through October 15.
Enacted into law in 1988,
this month recognizes the
contributions of Latino
and Hispanic Americans
in the United States
and their heritages, cultures,
and many achievements.
September 15 was chosen to
start the month of celebration
as it coincides with
the anniversary
of five Latin Americans
country's independence days.
September 16, 18, and 21 also
mark the independence of Mexico,
Chile, and Belize respectively.
Today we have the
honor of having
with us Representative
Pete Aguilar
in a moderated conversation
with law librarian
of Congress Jane Sanchez.
So Jane Sanchez is the 25th
law librarian of Congress.
She manages the operation
and policy administration
of the law library, the
world's largest collection
of legal material.
She assumed the position of law
librarian on February 6, 2017.
Prior to the law library,
Sanchez had been Chief
of Humanities and
Social Sciences
at the Library since
October 2014.
The division provides
research service
in the library's main reading
room, its local history
and genealogy section, its
digital reference team,
and its microfilm and
electronic resources center.
Under her leadership, services
to researchers expanded
and outreach through
the divisions, RSS feed,
has led to more robust use of
the collections and services.
She's also served as a
business unit managing director
at the U.S. Government
Publishing Office,
as an associate director
of Justice Libraries,
Justice Management Division,
U.S. Department of Justice,
as departmental head of
History and Cultural Literatures
at the Smithsonian
Institution Libraries,
and as an acquisitions manager
for electronic database at BNA,
Inc, a legal publisher, in
addition to library work
at Harvard and the
University of New Mexico.
She has received numerous awards
over the course of her career,
including from the U.S.
Department of Energy
for sustained superior service
and from the Justice
Management Division
and the Smithsonian Institution
for Workflow Improvements.
So Representative Pete
Aguilar represents the 31st
Congressional District
of California.
He was first elected
in 2014 and serves
on the House Appropriations
Committee in the 115th Congress.
He holds the leadership
positions of Whip,
of the Congressional Hispanic
Caucus, and is an assistant whip
in the House Democratic Caucus.
Representative Aguilar
is a voice
for middle-class families
throughout San Bernardino County
and prioritizes legislation that
will nurture more fair economy,
where everyone has
opportunities to succeed.
He is committed to
policies that create jobs,
reform our broken immigration
system, supports our students,
and safeguards vital programs
for seniors and veterans.
He resides in Redlands,
California with his wife
Alisha and their two sons.
So as a fellow Bulldog and the
University of Redland's alumni,
I'm really excited and happy
that you are here to join us.
And the Library of Congress
and Hispanic Cultural
Society welcomes you both.
So thank you, so much.
After the moderator
conversation,
we will open the floor up to
questions from the audience,
so please, stay tuned for
that and also you are welcome
for coffee and a
quick chat after.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane Sanchez: Good
morning, everyone.
I think this is on.
Is it on? Okay.
Good.
Great.
I'm going to have issues
with this thing here.
Good morning, everyone,
and Congressman Aguilar.
It is my great pleasure
to welcome you
to the Library of
Congress today.
We're so excited
that you're here.
>> Pete Aguilar: Thank you
so much for having me, Jane.
I really appreciate it and
thank you all for coming.
Jane and I were just talking
that clearly this 10 a.m. block,
there is a lot going
on here in Los Angeles.
[Laughter].
So thank you for choosing
to spend a little
bit of time with us.
>> Jane Sanchez: Yes.
Thank you for choosing us.
We're elated.
Thank you for joining
us in celebration
of Hispanic Heritage Month.
And if you're ready, I have
some questions for you.
>> Pete Aguilar: Okay.
I'm ready.
>> Jane Sanchez: Alright.
You are currently
the representative
from California's 31st
Congressional District
[inaudible] and the area
within the Inland Empire
that encompasses San Bernardino,
portions of Rancho Cucamonga,
and of course, Redlands.
As a former mayor of
Redlands and now Congressman
to the region, how did you
begin your political career?
>> Pete Aguilar: Well, I
began my political career
by just being devoted
to service.
Right. But the most difficult
part is kind of figuring
out where you go from there.
Quite honestly, I
was a staff member
for an elected official
and I loved that.
I thought that was exactly
where I wanted to be
and who I wanted to be.
I want to give my boss advice.
I want to help make
recommendations and suggestions.
I want to help make a
difference in the community.
But no way, I don't want to give
any of those speeches or have
to live with these
tough decisions.
And then, you know, the
more you get, I guess,
comfortable with in the
public policy forum,
the more comfortable I became
you know making decisions,
giving advice, having a
little bit more of an opinion
on where we stood, the
direction we should take.
And so, I started actually,
in the nonprofit world.
I got involved and that would be
my lesson to the young people,
is you know, just get
involved in your community.
No matter what you're doing,
no matter where you land it's
our responsibility to work
to make our communities a better
place and there are hundreds
and thousands of ways to do.
Some very publicly and
then some were private.
And so I got involved
with my community.
I [inaudible] the board.
I was President of
Board of Directors
for Habitat for Humanity.
I got to know members
of the community.
I started talking about
housing, affordable housing.
And then I got on the
Housing Commission
in the city of Redlands.
And that was a fun
outlet to dig into policy.
And then a vacancy on
the City Council opened
and I put my name in for that.
And I said, actually one
of my good friends, I said,
no I don't want to do that.
I just got married,
baby on the way.
This is not the right time.
And he said, there's always
going to be an excuse.
There's always going
to be a reason not
to do something that's
difficult.
But, you know, take the leap.
We're all there with you.
What's the worse
that can happen.
I said, they say no.
People say no.
And he said that's fine,
in the grand scheme
of things, you'll be okay.
I was appointed to the City
Council as the youngest member
of the City Council
in a hundred years.
Became the youngest mayor
to the city after that.
And it was just a lot
of fun to really dig
into local government,
try to find solutions
without party affiliation,
without any of that nonsense.
You're just working with five
people for the people to try
and make a difference
in your community.
>> Jane Sanchez: So
how was the transition
from mayor to congressman?
>> Pete Aguilar: Well, you have
to build a lot more coalition.
When there's four other
members of the City Council,
you need three votes
to get something done.
So I really just
needed two friends.
[Laughter].
But in most of the votes that
we had were actually a 4 to 1,
5 to zero, and that's
the way we liked it.
Here it's clearly
more difficult.
It's more partisan
environment once you put a D
or an R behind your name.
But I'll tell you there are ways
to be successful,
even in that climate.
Just like any relationship,
it just takes work.
You have to build
those relationships.
You have to reach out to your
colleagues across the aisle.
You have to understand and be
self-aware that you're not going
to agree with, you know,
everyone on every issue.
But find the two or three,
or eight or ten issues
that you do agree
with them on and try
to [inaudible] the
needle and try
to build a broader coalition.
I was proud to work with
Republican from South Texas,
worked on immigration.
We established a great
friendship as a result of that.
I really enjoy spending
time with him.
But we, you know, we're going
to disagree about the tax bill,
we're going to disagree
about healthcare, probably.
But we don't disagree
about immigration policy,
making sure that
we have [inaudible]
for so many young people.
So those are the things that we
can do when we work together.
It's hard in this environment.
But it's possible.
>> Jane Sanchez:
Okay, very good.
How did your Mexican-American
heritage affect your decision
to enter politics and how does
it now affect the policies
and legislation that
you're passionate about?
>> Pete Aguilar: My parents
and grandparents all grew
up in the city of San
Bernardino, where I'm from.
So walking around that city,
being around that community,
we always had -- we always knew
our diversity was our strength.
We always knew that that
sense of community kind
of brought us together.
And everyone of us was
afraid of our grandmother.
[Laughter].
So that's what really
united us as a community.
But, I think, as you're growing
up what you find is, you know,
the elected officials and
the people in the community,
and the business owners, doesn't
always look like our community.
So that's why that kind of
activism, and that discussion,
you know, really kind
of [inaudible] I've got.
This is what I want
for my community.
I want them to be proud of
their elected officials.
I want their elected officials
to look the communities
in which we serve.
And that's when I got a little
bit of the bug and wanting
to give back at a higher level.
And it's still to this
day the biggest source
of pride is walking into high
schools and middle schools
and talking to young people,
saying I went to this school,
this is what I was doing when
I was your age, and this is --
I didn't run for
student body leadership.
I didn't do any of that.
I was shy kid and usually
in the back, played sports,
and loved hanging out with his
friends, and to kind of change
and grow and to become a little
bit more community minded
for what my surroundings were
has been a point of pride
for me and my community.
>> Jane Sanchez: Very good.
So you are currently the Whip
of the Congressional
Hispanic caucus.
What was your pathway to
this leadership position
and what does it mean to be part
of the Congressional
Hispanic caucus?
>> Pete Aguilar:
So there's 31 of us
in the Congressional
Hispanic caucus,
20 House members,
and two Senators.
First Latino to be a
Congressional Hispanic caucus
member is now among us,
Catherine Cortez Masto from --
a Senator from Nevada.
So it's been fun to
be part of that group
because we share that identity.
We share the communities
that we represent.
But it's also forced me to think
through, okay, what's important
to New Yorkers, what's important
to Floridians and Texans,
New Mexicans, and Arizonians.
We're all representing
similar communities.
But also, you know,
Mexican-American is my heritage.
But there are Puerto Ricans in
our caucus, there are members
from Central America,
heritage from Central America.
And so make sure we because
Latino is so inclusive
in our communities making sure
that we're truly
representing everyone,
has been a focal
point of what we do.
But it's allowed me to
have these member-to-member
conversations about what's
important to your district,
keeping in mind that not
every district is the same.
There are members of the
Hispanic caucus who are Latino
or Latina but maybe they don't
represent a very large Latino
or Latina population and
so be mindful of that.
Maybe their district is what
we would call a swing district,
as well.
And so knowing that each of
us represents a unique piece
in the community and we all
come together and want to work
with one another on
these shared issues is
so incredibly fascinating
and important.
>> Jane Sanchez: So
what does a Whip do?
>> Pete Aguilar: Yes.
So the Whip position
is a lot of fun
and Steny Hoyer is the
Democratic Whip for our caucus.
And so I've kind of
learned from Steny.
But I will tell you the
single biggest thing
for the Whip position
is knowing your members,
knowing your colleagues and
having your finger on the pulse
of what they want
to get accomplished.
You have to be willing
to put the shared goals
of the group before
your own personal goals.
So the Whip position means
you need to know are there,
in a group of 30,
are there 20 votes
for what we're talking about?
Are there 25 votes?
Or are there only five?
And maybe there are only five
but I'm one of those five.
You have to have
the self-awareness,
you have to have the leadership
to be able to say, I will go --
we will go where our
caucus wants us to go.
And that doesn't mean that you
can't continue to learn and grow
and I always reserve the right
to try to convince my colleagues
that I'm on the right side, even
if I'm in that smaller minority.
But knowing where
your colleagues are
and giving them space to make
those decisions, I think is one
of the things from my
perspective is truly a tell-tale
of Congressional leadership.
You want to be able
to ask people
where they are on an issue.
What is -- how would your
district analyze this issue?
Where do you come down on it?
Well, this is what I would
do and this is how I talk
about it in my community.
I mean, if you think you
could get to a yes on this.
But if they say no or I can't
or maybe, you have to know how
to calibrate, how to continue
that educational discussion.
And we see this, questions
about the Congressional
Hispanic caucus
but I see this is a
broader Democratic caucus
that I worked in.
There are a lot of our
colleagues who want
to be helpful to the
Latino community.
They want to do what's right.
They just don't always
know what that means
or how to talk about it.
And they don't know our
community on issues.
So I think a lot of this
is also our responsibility
in the Hispanic caucus
to talk to our colleagues
who don't know these
issues and to let them know
where the community stands on
something and how we might talk
about it or how you
might talk about it
if you represented a district
that doesn't look like mine
to give people the
background and the information
to make an informed decision.
But at the end of the day
we just have to respect
where your colleagues
are on this
and that's the beautiful part of
this institution is being able.
I'm the only one that's here to
represent my entire community.
And that is an incredibly
heavy weight that I have
and each of us has that.
So I trust that my colleagues
are making the right decision
for their communities as well.
>> Jane Sanchez: Very good.
The Library of Congress
knows your office well.
And your engagement with
our surplus book program.
How would you define your
relationship to the library?
>> Pete Aguilar: We were talking
about this a little earlier.
I am just such a huge fan of the
Library of Congress and the work
that everyone in this
institution does.
But, I'll tell you,
a lot of work
that they do is unknown,
under appreciated.
And so, part of, I think, what
we need to do as members is
to be advocates for
the institution.
But to also let our colleagues
know about programs like this.
That maybe aren't
as widely utilized.
And to let them know
the services
that the library can provide
to our communities back
[inaudible] this is one
that has been so
impressive to me.
The fact that the library
is so generous with books
for our local school districts.
We worked with you to send
a little care package.
There was a shooting in a
school in San Bernardino,
where I'm from, and to be able
to send a care package of books
to this school after that
event to hopefully, kind of,
raise their spirits, give them
something new and something
that they can tie them to
us was really powerful.
And I always love that
it's stamped, it's courtesy
of the Library of Congress.
Because I want that young person
to also open that and say,
what's the Library of Congress?
And well, let's research that.
Let's talk about that.
Let's talk about
what that means.
And to know that someone across
the country was generous enough
to send them these books
is just means a lot to me
and means a lot to
all of us members.
But it was -- when
you come and visit us,
in our Congressional offices,
you probably told me
about this program.
Probably told me 50 things
that you do but, you know,
you just get into
town, and you're trying
to build your staff
and it's very tough.
So it was a couple of
other members saying, hey,
do you do this program?
You should make sure
your staff follows up
and we're all doing this.
So it's also a little bit
of that peer pressure.
And so that's where it's
important for members
to know the services that you
guys provide because I want
to be a resource to those new
first-year members who are going
to come in December
and say, hey,
be sure you utilize
these services
and you talk to the librarian.
>> Jane Sanchez: Great, great.
I hope you know about our
initial library services
for the blind and
physically handicapped,
and also our veteran's
history project, as well.
>> Pete Aguilar: Yes, yes.
>> Jane Sanchez:
Those are important.
>> Pete Aguilar: Those
are important projects.
And a little bit
about my history.
My first job was working
for my grandfather
who was a legally blind operator
and there is actually a federal
program that trained him,
called the Randolph-Sheppard
Act.
And he served in the
Korean War, he came back,
and he lost his eyesight
through a disease
when my dad was in his teens.
And my grandfather
had to be retrained.
And he didn't know that
this program existed.
A friend had told him and
my grandmother about it.
And so he became a legally
blind owner-operator.
So the programs that you
provide go far in line.
And that's what I appreciate
so much about the library.
And so much about our processes.
Those investments to make sure
that everyone has a chance
and an opportunity
that are so vital.
>> Jane Sanchez: Thank you.
What have been the legislative
goals of the Hispanic caucus
for the 115th Congress and
what progress has been made?
>> Pete Aguilar: Well, it feels
like we've been playing a lot
of defense, obviously.
And this isn't a
partisan discussion
and I'll tell you it's
been incredibly frustrating
because I do feel that the
administration is either
planned, executed,
or fomented some
of the most anti-immigrant
positions
that we've seen in a long time.
And so to try to dial that
back, try to push back
with information, to try to
make sure that my colleagues
and I stand up for the right
things and that we push back.
You can see the administrations
policies
when they're wrong
has been something
that the Hispanic caucus
has tried to execute
and put together a
plan on how we do that.
It's been very public
that our plans,
our focus are comprehensive
immigration reform.
But we don't just
want to be the caucus
about comprehensive immigration
reform when we have Latinos
and Latinas who are in
incredible positions,
in small business committees,
energy and commerce committees
throughout this Congress.
We have individuals who have
the skill set and working
on these issues for decades.
But this is clearly an
issue that is very personal
to us and means a lot.
And so to ensure that we
are making progress toward
comprehensive immigration
reform has been a goal.
And clearly the most important
thing right now is making sure
that we have a permitted
fix for guideline to ensure
that young people
who have DACA status.
Those who are DACA eligible
have a path to citizenship,
is something that we will
continue to fight for.
That's the bill that I
authored and a bill that I plan
to continue to be a part of
in the next Congress as well.
>> Jane Sanchez: Recently
we've seen a renewed interest
in politics and political
involvement
from younger generations.
What advice and words of
encouragement would you give
to those who may be interested
in getting involved in local
and national politics?
>> Pete Aguilar: Do it.
[Laughter].
Jump in the water is fine.
We need -- and here's
the important thing.
We need young people to feel
committed to public service.
And I want people to see members
of Congress conduct themselves
in the right way, to work
in a bipartisan manner.
I want people to see that and to
say, yes, I want to do that job.
I want to serve my community.
I don't want them to see
the food fight of, you know,
what's on TV sometimes,
the back and forth,
and to get discouraged and
say, I don't want to do that.
You know, so, how we conduct
ourselves is also incredibly
important because we
need another generation
and continued generations
of young people to say,
I want to serve, I want to make
a difference in my community.
It may not always be
the most glamorous,
it may not always
make the most money,
but I can make an incredible
difference in my community.
And so that's what
I hope that you --
I hope that you get there.
I hope that you find that
sense of community in place
and want to give back.
Like all of our parents and
grandparents to be able to make
that community a better place
and to leave it a little
bit better than we found it.
That's getting more difficult
to say that we are doing that.
And so we're going
to need policymakers
and thought leaders
to help us get there.
The only way we do
it is by making sure
that the leadership tables
look like the communities
in which we serve, to make sure
that everyone has an opportunity
to give feedback and
help make a difference.
>> Jane Sanchez: What does
Hispanic Heritage Month mean
to you and how will your office
be celebrating this month?
>> Pete Aguilar: We attend a
lot of events and celebrate
and honor our heritage
and hone our culture.
But we try to do
this year-round, too.
Making sure that we honor
every culture in a community
and to make sure that
they feel welcome.
And that's the story of
our country is to make sure
that immigrants are
welcomed and appreciated.
And so, we want to make sure
that, especially this month,
we're doing everything we
can to honor our communities
and to make sure that we're
doing outreach, to make sure
that everyone feels
that they have a place
in our society, community.
And to make sure that they
are loved and respected,
I feel is important
piece of what we can do
and that's what our office
will continue to plan to do.
>> Jane Sanchez: Great.
Once again, thank you.
Today is a reminder
that diversity is one
of our country's
greatest strength.
And Hispanic-Americans have
always been and will continue
to be a key part of this rich
mosaic, which makes our country
so unique and special.
With that being said, maybe --
let's check to see if
we have any questions
from our gathering today.
And we are delighted to have
our Gonzaga students here today.
Thank you for coming.
>> Pete Aguilar:
>> Jane Sanchez: Yes.
So questions?
Oh, come on.
>> My name is Carlos
[inaudible].
How do you feel that we as
Latinos do to overcome this gap
that we see at [inaudible].
You're at a position where
you can give us advice.
So what's something you can
say to us that will push us
and drive us to be
comfortable with that.
Can you talk about that?
>> Pete Aguilar: I think
what I would tell --
thank you, Carlos,
I appreciate it.
What I would tell you is if
you are just by virtue of being
in those seats, you are doing
things that make your families
and your community so proud.
But the road needs
to go further.
You need to continue to
make your families proud,
to continue your education,
and to continue being thoughtful
members of the community.
That's how we make a difference.
And what I would say is, you
know, many people are going
to be the first in your
family to do a lot of things.
I was.
I was the first in my
family to go to college.
I was the first in my family
-- this sounds very weird,
but it was -- I was
in my mid-20s,
and I was making more money
than my parents were
making at the time.
And there's a responsibility
that goes behind that.
And it isn't about
dollar and cents.
It's about the responsibility
to pay it forward.
The responsibility to
help teach someone else,
to help mentor someone
else to be successful.
And so, as you go
through your schooling,
as you go through your life
education, you're going
to meet people who help you.
And the most special thing is
the individuals who help you,
who you learn later in life,
there is no reason why
they needed to help me.
They took an interest in me
and they saw something in you
when you didn't see
it in yourself.
And I have those
individuals in my life.
And it's tough not to
get emotional about it.
There were individuals who
believed in me much more
than I believed in myself,
when I was in college
and when I went into business.
And I wouldn't be
here without them.
But they meant the world to me.
So make sure you just pause
and that you think about what
that individual is
doing to help you.
It could be giving
you political advice,
it could be giving you
educational advice.
It could be giving you an
opportunity to have a job.
And so what that individual
has gone through, and every one
of the individuals
that I can think of,
three out of the four were
individuals in my community
who were older, Caucasian,
and they saw something in me
because they knew that our
communities were changing.
And they knew that -- they felt
that I could make a difference.
And they thought that
just by giving me a shot,
giving me some advice,
that they could help.
And so find people,
surround yourself with people
who give you the
benefit of the doubt,
who will help you along the way.
Those are the individuals who
you want to interact with.
Those are the people you're
going to learn the most from.
And they're going to help open
doors for you and they're going
to be your advocates and
throughout life you're going
to have those individuals.
And later when you reflect it's
going to mean the most to you.
You may not know it when
you're in the middle of it
but it's going to mean
the absolute most to you.
And it's going to drive you
to make better decisions
and to help open the door
for someone else behind you.
>> Hi, I'm Justin [inaudible].
What is the one experience
that you had
that really has taught you
an important life lesson
that you would like to pass on?
>> Pete Aguilar: I'd say,
Justin, my first experience,
I guess, as a community
organizer
in politics kind
of taught me a lot.
I was 10 years old.
And the Exxon Valdez
spill happened.
It was a big oil spill
that dominated the news.
Way before you guys were born
and now you're making
me feel old.
[Laughter].
I'm a pretty young guy.
I saw these images on
the TV and I just --
it drove me to want
to do something.
I didn't know what to do.
You see images of wildlife,
birds, or oil slick all over
and the clean -- the
massive clean up efforts.
And so, what I did was,
I was 10 years old,
my parents were not
political at all.
And they voted every
election, took us to the polls.
They showed us the
importance of that.
But they didn't talk
about who they voted for,
we didn't have those
family conversations.
And so I just started
writing letters.
I wrote a letter to the CEO of
Exxon, basically telling them
that you guys messed up and
you need to pay for this.
[Laughter].
And you're a terrible company.
Something like that.
[Laughter].
And so, I wrote it
and I felt okay.
But I also felt that
I should share this.
And so, I went door to
door with my neighbor.
And I got people to sign
the petition, basically.
Just a lined piece of paper
and I said this is
the letter I wrote
and I hope you share
this position with me
and I hope you can sign
your name and I'm going
to send it to the CEO.
And my neighbors were like,
what the heck are you doing?
[Laughter].
But I think they all appreciated
that that's kind of who I was
and it was a lesson,
and that was kind
of my evolution and my growth.
And what it taught me was, you
know, don't be afraid to get
out of your comfort zone.
You know, don't be afraid
to try something different
that you haven't done.
If it's who you are and
that's what you believe.
It's not wrong.
And so, I also think that your
generation is the most open
about so many things that other
generations are not open to.
So use that as a tool to
encourage other generations,
my generation and others to
be more open about who you are
and I think that's an
incredibly helpful.
But I took it to school,
I wouldn't let any
of my friends sign the petition.
I said, you're not
18, you can't vote.
You shouldn't sign this.
But I went to all the teachers.
[Laughter].
And so, then I sent it.
I don't think it was 40
or 50 signatures on it.
My aunt convinced me to send
it certified mail so I knew,
I got a little postcard
back that they received it.
I kept that postcard for years.
So, you know, that
was my first lesson
in organizing, in leadership.
And it taught me a lot
about just kind of getting
out of your comfort zone.
Being a shy kid doesn't mean
you can't make a difference
or have your voice heard.
We don't want to put all the
pressure on the Gonzaga kids.
[Laughter].
>> Representing [inaudible].
I wanted to ask you about how
others see you in Congress?
When there's this
message of America first
and we're trying to
stifle diversity.
What is the message that we can
bring forward to help others say
that diversity is important and
how do you carry the narrative
that your past [inaudible]
community
over the majority of Americans?
>> Pete Aguilar: Yes.
That's a great question.
And my response is every
community deserves a voice
at the table and every
individual matter.
I think it's generally accepted
among my colleagues is what we
should be doing.
I think the voices we hear and
some of this fervor we hear
from the administration
is counter to that.
But I find it -- I find that
having those conversations
with my colleagues makes me
feel a little bit more at ease.
And I'm talking about
both sides of the aisle.
Folks understand that we
need to solve these issues.
We might not always agree on how
to get there but I do have a lot
of confidence in the
institution of Congress.
I think that we can do
a lot more to ensure
that we raise our voices
and we stand up to wrongs
where we see them as a group.
I do feel that we can do more.
But I do think that we are
building coalitions in order
to accomplish that goal.
And that's what it's
going to take.
Because not every
member, as I mentioned,
is going to feel comforted
knowing what it took --
what's important to
them in a community.
So it's our job to
[inaudible] a segment
of the community is just not as
large as mine or someone else's.
And so my belief is that
they want to do right
by [inaudible] districts.
So we just have to show them.
We just don't know how, yet.
And so, it's on us
to show them how.
To show them that the Latino
dream is the American dream.
Better jobs, better wages,
all the affordable healthcare,
access to education,
better life for our kids.
That's the American dream.
How is that -- how
are Latinos different?
We're not.
We want the exact same thing,
clean air, clean water.
Those are things
that Latinos want.
Not every Latino
wants comprehensive
immigration reform.
And we shouldn't act
as if that's the case.
But everyone wants
a better community,
better life their kids.
So let's start with
that as the umbrella
by which we can have
a conversation
about all these other issues.
>> I actually have
followed up question.
You mentioned the DACA bill --
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Pete Aguilar:
That's a great question.
And I think what we try to do
is you almost work backwards.
It's what's the goal?
Who do we want to help?
And then let's make sure
that the legislation fits
that -- fits that goal.
So at first, quite honestly,
we had to decide in our piece
of legislation who
we wanted to help.
And then that would serve
as the basis for the --
road map for the legislation
that we would develop.
And clearly, and I
was very selfish,
in all of my conversations
with my Republican colleagues.
I would rather try
to help more people.
And so that meant removing
barriers, removing age caps,
that meant removing whether
someone actually has that status
or whether they meet
the DACA criteria,
what we call DACA eligible.
I want them to --
I wanted to make it
as expansive as possible.
So my colleagues agreed.
And so we were able to do
something that was a piece
of legislation, that was more
than 700,000 who
have DACA status.
It was two -- it would help 2
million eligible [inaudible]
people receive the
path to citizenship.
But you have to work backwards.
And you have to, you know,
you have to work to ensure
that we honor that humanity
and that we're all
focused on the same goals.
But you have to stop to
realize that not everyone
in Congress reads these
pieces of legislation.
And part of what we have to
do is we have to message it
and we have to sell it.
And so, honestly, we
told many individuals,
look help us with this DACA fix.
This will put folks on
the path to citizenship.
And that was all they needed.
We didn't even get into
the details about age caps.
We didn't get into details
of you have a free pass
to citizenship if you
work, go to school,
if you've served the military.
Some people wanted
more information
and some people didn't.
Some people this
is a different part
and why I think it puts a
[inaudible] on relationships.
And some people see the
messenger and say, okay, yes.
I've got no -- I've worked
with you on things before.
I know that when you
talk to my staff,
but I know that you wouldn't
try to pitch me on something
that wasn't right
for my community.
And so, I think, that puts a
premium on the relationships
that we have as members
to say, hey, you know,
worked with me on stuff.
Let's talk about this.
Let me answer your
questions here.
I want to pitch to
your staff on this.
I want to go through
the details of this.
Because oftentimes, what became
a hurdle were leadership offices
here in Congress that
were giving members
incorrect information.
And so we had to debunk that.
We had to put on out
our own topic points.
We had to put out
frequently asked questions.
And we had to really work
on a one-on-one basis
with our colleagues
to educate them
and tell them [inaudible]
piece of legislation.
So making sure that the goal
was always the same for us.
We have good partners and a good
piece of bipartisan legislation.
And the goal is the
same for both of you.
That's a great place to start.
And so that's what we try to do.
There are a lot of other
social and societal discussions
that we could have
under that discussion.
But honestly, we were
just so laser focused
on how do we add
five co-sponsors?
How do we get this
think on the floor?
How do we improve this
coalition of the bill?
You know, those were the
things that we were focused on,
the very micro issues
of [inaudible] something
that happens.
And it was just an honor
to be part of that.
I'm going to go down to
Texas and talk a little bit
about the path forward
on immigration
with Representative
Hurd this weekend.
And I hope that we can continue
this bipartisan dialogue
that needs to --
productive piece
of legislation that
we can enact.
And put on the President's
desk in the next Congress.
Again, I want to thank you and
the Society for having me --
I don't think it's time
to close yet but thank you
so much for the invitation.
It really means the world to
me to be able to share some
of my experiences and talk
about my time in Congress.
>> Alda Migoni: Oh, thank you.
Before closing there are still
a little time for questions.
But we -- I do feel kind
of separated from Congress
and I suppose you are our boss.
There are a lot of times
when [inaudible response]
and I just really appreciate
that you took the time to speak
to us and to [inaudible] the
issues and to speak [inaudible].
So that's great.
We are a tunnel away.
[Laughter].
Any other questions?
>> Jane Sanchez: We
have someone here, too.
>> Hi. My name is [inaudible].
My question is Congressman,
there is talk
about [inaudible] task force
American citizens along the
[inaudible] Mexican borders.
What are your thoughts
about this?
Do you support it?
>> Pete Aguilar:
No and this stems
from a Washington Post
article that was recently put
out where the Trump
administration is challenging
citizenship, challenging
DACA immigration
that individuals have
used to secure citizenship
and legal permanent resident
status and citizenship.
And look, I think -- and
this is what's difficult.
I want we -- there's
a lot we need to learn
about the questions they're
asking and what they're doing.
I have signed on to some letters
to the Secretary to ask some
of these questions, of USCIS
and of Homeland Security.
And I look forward
to the responses.
What I would say is, we
don't know enough yet.
But what we have heard,
troubles [inaudible].
And I feel like that statement
can apply to so many things here
in the immigration space
from this administration.
But I want to make decisions
that are based on fact,
based on correct information.
But if they are going to
individuals, if they are looking
at documents and
challenging documents
without basis then I have
a huge problem with that.
If they are targeting border
communities and creating hurdles
and roadblocks in order to
stifle someone's continued --
LPR status or their
citizenship, then I'm going
to have a huge problem
with their activities.
So we need to make sure that
we get the right information.
We get to know who
they are talking to.
And what questions
they are asking.
But I'll tell you, certainly
the appropriations committee
and all that's questioned,
you know,
what we were doing in committee.
I passed an amendment that
surprised me, passed unanimously
in the Homeland Security
subcommittee
that prohibits the
administration
from deporting anyone
with active, valid status.
And active, valid status who
has served in the military.
And I thought it was
going to be controversial
and they accepted the amendment.
We haven't passed that bill.
That's one of the CR
that is carried forward.
But we have our colleagues
on record that they are --
that they want to pause
on any deportation
of individuals with DACA status,
which is a good place to start.
[inaudible] other proposals,
like that you mentioned,
that give me a great deal
of anxiety and heartburn
because it's [inaudible]
to send a message
to our community
that in some way,
the administration is watching
and action you have taken
in the past could
be brought back up.
public charges in the
news, this week as well.
So the fact that the
administration wants to try
to prevent U.S. born citizens
from utilizing services
for United States citizens,
whether that be SNAP,
whether that's Headstart,
or whether that's healthcare,
troubles me greatly.
Because those are things,
I think, are out of bounds
and those are things
that are in line
with who we are as a community.
Definitely in line
with the guidance
that Congress has given.
So we need to make sure that we
push back but we need to do it
in a way that uses information
that we're gathering right now,
the administration has been very
slow to give us those details.
So I look forward to survey and
to getting more information.
And if there is a change
in the next Congress,
I would hope the
administration will be --
our tools to encourage them
to be more responsible
will be utilized.
So we'll continue to ask these
questions and to make sure
that they're treating everyone
correctly without harassment,
without discrimination.
[ Inaudible question ]
A little bit of what I said
before is to surround yourself
with people who believe in you.
Right?
And once you have that
core group of friends
and family members, it doesn't
matter what anybody else says.
You can turn off that noise.
But, look, my path is
probably similar to yours.
I have people -- when I was
accepted to college, who said --
I got a high school classmate
who was valedictorian
and we went to the same
university and he said,
that I got into the same
school he did because of I got
to check a box that said
I was Hispanic or Latino.
And in some way, in their minds,
the contributions and the work
that I had done in high
school to get there
and so there are going
to be individuals
who minimize what you've
done to get to where you are.
And the tough part of it is,
you know, pushing through that,
knowing who you are, surrounding
yourself with friends who are
in similar positions, making
sure you always have somebody
to talk to about that.
It may not always
be a family member
because not every
family member is going
to have those experiences.
So making sure you have this
corporate friends around you
who are looking out
for you is important.
That will help you push
through that adversity.
But don't every let
anyone minimize the work
that you've done to
get to where you are.
And now different people
handle things differently.
I just kind of shrugged
and kind of laughed it off.
And that's fine.
I don't mind that, I'm a
pretty even keeled person.
I'm not a screamer or yeller.
But I was pretty
fired up about that.
And it drove me to want to
do better and to want to --
you know, it's always good,
it's always healthy to walk
with a little chip
on your shoulder.
To have self-awareness
to say, look,
not everyone thinks
I can do this.
But I think I can do this.
And I think a little
bit of that is healthy.
And so just know that
there are a lot of people
that want you to succeed.
And your community
needs you to succeed.
And so that needs to always
be in your background.
People you've never met.
People you don't know.
They want you to succeed.
They want you to do well.
And that will help you to kind
of push through any negativity
that you may hear or see.
>> My name is [inaudible]
Gonzaga.
You mentioned that you were
the first in your family
that had gone to college.
My mother also was.
Why do you --
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Pete Aguilar: Yes.
So my advice is try everything.
And that's why -- I love --
I went to a liberal arts
college and I loved that.
I went in thinking that I was
going to be a business guy.
I loved business.
It was kind of what
piqued my interest.
And I kept taking these
government classes
and finally a government's
professor said, hey,
I'm going to have to kick you
out of class unless
you change your major.
[Laughter].
And so you don't know what
you're truly going to love
until you try a bunch
of these things.
Right?
That's why your parents let you
play musical instrument while
you're doing sports,
while you're doing art.
You just don't know.
I mean, I've got a 12-year-old
and a 9-year-old right now.
And they are driving
my wife and I crazy
because they want
to try everything.
And we want them to do that.
We want them to find something
that they're truly
passionate and love.
I'll tell you, when you do that
and the light clicks, you know,
your Mom's going
to be proud of you.
You're going to feel like you're
ready to make the next step.
So that's going to be a powerful
thing but don't feel the need
to just do one or two things
or just try one or two things.
You know, you guys are
going to be going to college
and visiting schools and you
know, visit a couple of schools,
visit some that you think isn't
necessarily, like, I don't know
if that's right for me.
But just get out of your
comfort zone and see.
Walk around that campus and see
if you can envision
yourself being there
and contributing there.
Those are things, I think that
will make your parents proud.
And will lead to you
being successful.
But, you know, get out
of your comfort zone
and take some different classes
that you may not always like.
I really think that will
help make you a more
well-rounded student.
It will help you focus
on what you truly like.
I didn't know about how
much I disliked science
until I took astronomy.
And I said, this is hard.
There's a lot of math.
I thought I was going
to look at the stars.
[Laughter].
That was astronomy.
Man. And so, I said, I'm
going back to government.
I told my friends I picked
government over business,
I doubled major in both.
But I picked government
because I loved that I could --
it only mattered if I could make
an argument in those classes.
If I could make an argument it
didn't matter what my position
was as long as I could prove it.
In business and in math,
right, there's always answers.
There's always answers
to these questions.
But in government, let's
talk about these issues.
Let's talk about 2nd amendment.
Let's talk about
what this means.
And if you can, you know, argue
it and believe it and back it
up with facts and
citations, you're going
to do well in those classes.
I wanted to do that.
I wanted to kind
of make my argument
and to give my viewpoints.
So be comfortable enough to
know that there are other things
out there that you may not
even have taken classes
on that you may grow to love
and be passionate about.
Every one of us in professionals
has these types of stories.
So just be prepared
that you're going
to always continue to learn.
I tried to -- in these
roles people will give you
a microphone.
They expect you to talk for,
you know, a long, long time.
And I truly just love hearing
what other people think
and listening and learning.
Never stop, and the
librarians will tell you thin,
this is a journey,
never stop learning.
And just be aware enough
that even if something is
where you truly love,
keep learning,
keep reading, keep absorbing.
And you're going to do --
you're going to be just fine.
You're going to make
your Mom proud.
But don't feel it's a huge
weight on your shoulders.
Right. You're doing exactly
-- she may know sacrifices
and she took those -- she made
those decisions so you could be
in the chair that
you're in right now.
Know that, acknowledge that.
But that's not a weight.
You should be proud of that.
Your parents are going
to be proud of you
in your next steps
and your journey.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
And we're all excited to
see what you guys do next.
Having to honor your family and
your culture and your heritage.
My grandmother told me two
things every time I would
leave here.
I could just go to the
store and come back.
And she'd tell me two things.
Right. Which are to be careful
and never forget who you are
and where you came from.
She tells me that and
I always think about it
because I have an obligation
to family, to community
to make this world a
little better place.
That's what I want to do.
And that's what you could do.
I know that's what you could do.
[ Applause ]
>> Alda Migoni: On behalf
of the Library of Congress
and the Hispanic Cultural
Society at the Library
of Congress, thank you so much
for this moderated conversation.
I'd like to thank
you both personally
for just a really illuminating
and fun conversation.
And this is a turbulent time.
So it's great to have
these words of wisdom.
And I'm really happy that
we also have our high school
students in attendance.
I did want to plug,
on the same note,
we had a HACU intern
ask a question.
And I'm a former HACU intern.
So before you leave
off to college,
look up these type
of internships.
It's a Hispanic Association
of Colleges and Universities.
They give you paid government
postings when you're in college.
So that will actually help
you try everything, you know.
You could be placed
in a government agency
like the Library of Congress
and realize you want
to be a librarian.
Or realize you don't,
and that's fine, too.
[Laughter].
But thank you again.
And I do want to plug the rest
of our Hispanic Heritage Month
celebrations will continue.
Tomorrow we have the America's
Award in honor of two authors
who have produced great
children's and youth literature
and in the honor of
Hispanic Heritage,
Latino and Latin-American
communities.
So please celebrate with us
tomorrow here at the library
in the Jefferson Building.
So thank you, everyone,
for attending.
[ Applause ]